what is the number typically
you're only supposed to spend per month
on your mortgage payment isn't it
supposed to be a third yeah it's
supposed to be a third
so for a 2 000 square foot house that's
only three bedroom if you need to make
20 grand pre-tax money what do you need
to make to be able to afford a third of
a go into a mortgage payment they said
sixty thousand dollars i said what's
that times twelve seven twenty i said
how many guys are gonna make 720 in
california the next three to five years
i said now let me ask you this how many
are still planning on staying in the
state of california you should see what
happened i said how many of you just
based on that are open to the idea of
leaving the state in the next three to
five years you know what happened what
happened of the 70 half of them raised
their hands and they said that's just
not sustainable
i said then let me speak to the other
guys that are planning on staying here
how the hell are you going to get to 7
20. tell me i'm curious